let me just acknowledge one of our
distinguished visitors who's here today
Secretary of State George Shultz
secretary Schultz is just back from
Washington where he testified last week
in support of a carbon tax this lecture
is named after our classmate Conrad in
Van Google Berg who died 25 years ago we
remember him most for his persistent
concern for the planet in his memory
friends and family set up a fund to
support environmental programs at the
business school including case studies
internships and recycling initiatives
the CVG funds annual lecture has become
a major gathering for the business
school and the entire Stanford community
over the years we've had a distinguished
list of speakers from heads of EPA CEOs
of an of companies in the fortune 500
and directors of leading environmental
groups our speaker today Mary Nichols
adds more depth to this legacy Mary
serves as chairman of the California Air
Resources Board which experts believe is
the most influential air pollution
agency in the United States if not the
world rules concerning emissions from
cars and trucks power plants factories
and agriculture get adopted in
California and then spread to other
states the federal EPA and even to other
countries Mary has led the agency twice
when Jerry Brown was first governor from
1975 to 83 and then since 2007 when
Governor Schwarzenegger asked her to
return
Governor Brown reappointed her in 2011
in this hyper partisan political world
two governors one Democrat one
Republican knew competence when they saw
it in between her time at ARB Mary
served as assistant administrator for
air at the US EPA during the Clinton
administration
she was also secretary for resources of
the state of California among other
posts Mary Nichols has been a dogged
defender of assembly bill 32 the state's
climate and clean energy law in the face
of a severe recession and an oil company
backed ballot initiative that would have
repealed the law
Mary is focused on showing the world
that it's possible to reduce emissions
and grow the economy she's done it
through a remarkably transparent
regulatory process in which businesses
environmental groups and average
citizens have all had their say at the
end of the day
chairman Nichols leadership on climate
has kept our state moving forward when
the head of EPA Lisa Jackson announced
that she was leaving government Mary
Nichols name appeared on many short
lists for who was best qualified to
succeed administrator Jackson last
Monday President Obama chose somebody
else perhaps realizing that California
and the nation needed Mary to stay right
here
so please welcome our CVG speaker for
2012-13 school year Mary Nichols the
goals for cap and trade were in
California and as well how these feeds
in the brother framework of the a b32
policy sure well let me take you back to
2006 when the California Legislature
passed a b 32 I wasn't there I was at
UCLA actually running an
interdisciplinary environmental program
following what was happening in the
California Legislature but not all that
closely because it seemed as though it
wasn't really likely that this bill was
going to pass and it took a sort of a
heroic effort at the very end by a
number of people to actually pull the
legislation together and when it was
passed it was done with a compromise
that was brokered between the governor
and the legislature so the governor who
of course was a Republican it was a very
strong believer in market-based programs
and he insisted that the cap-and-trade
program be a feature of the California
climate program the legislature under
the firm control of Democratic
leadership was
extremely suspicious of market
mechanisms in general and cap-and-trade
in particular and they did not want this
to be part of the of the bill at all
they wanted it to be purely regulatory
so the compromise that led to the bill
finally passing and being signed by the
governor was that the Air Resources
Board which was handed the assignment to
implement this legislation was permitted
to institute a market-based mechanism
they didn't even use the word
cap-and-trade if they made certain
findings that it would not interfere
with air pollution control programs that
it would not create any undue are on
disproportionate impacts on poor
communities disadvantaged communities
that it was more effective than the pure
regulatory program and so forth so that
was the that was the slate that I saw
when I got to Sacramento in 2007 and was
handed the assignment of implementing
this law so I guess these answers
somewhat my second question but I
imagine that took out a carbon tax very
early from the discussion or was it the
still part of the discussion actually
the word climate tax climate carbon tax
were not uttered by anyone this was not
a partisan question at that point
nowadays there are at least a few brave
souls in Washington who are willing to
speak up on behalf of of a carbon tax
and I'm very happy to hear that they
invited secretary Schultz to come and
and speak on that topic because I've
heard him on it and is very eloquent but
no one thought that the legislature was
interested in passing a tax it's very
difficult to do under any circumstances
but under the rules that apply in
California it would have taken a
two-thirds vote and at that point there
was no way that Republicans in the
legislature would have voted for any
form of a new tax so that that topic was
just off the table so one of the other
challenges that come up
when implementing climate regulation is
that it often is part of having
competitiveness effects so by taxing
California or by putting a cap-and-trade
program in California we are making
Californian firms less competitive so I
was wondering how did you manage the
concerns about leakage during the
discussions of a b32
and how did you think about the worries
that some activity you would would
relocate out of California well first of
all before I answer your question I
think I need to set the stage a little
better than we have up until now
so a b32 didn't come out of nowhere it
was and it wasn't just the brainchild of
one or two you know leftist legislators
it was in fact something that was very
strongly supported by a number of
businesses in California it was
certainly the leadership came from our
own Silicon Valley from our venture
capitalists who were investing in all
kinds of clean technologies businesses
that had ideas about technologies that
they wanted to promote and even a b32
was supported by some of our larger
businesses who stand to incur higher
costs as a result of this of having to
do something about climate change but
who believed enough in California as a
laboratory as a as an economy that was
big enough to do something meaningful
but still contained enough so that you
could do something that might be an
experiment here and if the experiment
was not completely successful that you
could change it and I think it's a
really important factor when you're
talking about policy as opposed to
theory to understand that one of the
reasons why California historically has
been able to be a leader in
environmental policy and now an energy
policy and climate policy is that
we have been known over the years as a
place where legislation can pass
reasonably quickly and can also be
amended when it needs to be so you don't
have these decade-long struggles to pass
bills here in general that that you have
at the national level okay so your
question is about impacts on businesses
that might feel that they were less
competitive as a result of it well again
a little bit of context cap-and-trade is
the thing that most people talk about
right now it's the it's the hot issue in
terms of a b32 because it's the latest
thing that we've implemented but it
actually is not the biggest piece of our
a b32 program California's program to
meet our climate goal of reducing
greenhouse gas emissions in 2020 to 1990
levels is controlled by a plan which has
many different elements to it the
foundation of it is actually our auto
emission standards which began much
earlier back in 2004 California began
working on greenhouse gas emission
standards for new motor vehicles for
cars and light trucks and in our plan
for meeting ab32
we have a number of other pieces that
are directed at specific pieces of the
economy that are big contributors to
global warming so the low carbon fuel
standard the renewable portfolio
standard for electricity and so forth
the cap-and-trade program comes as the
icing on the cake it's a it's the top
piece of that whole set of layers that
gets us to the to the goal and in that
sense it's it works together with all
these other regulations and policies to
allow somewhat more diversity and more
opportunity for the companies that are
covered by it to find emissions
reductions in other places including
from sectors that aren't even um
the cap so it's a way of actually
opening up the program and allowing for
more freedom when it comes to figuring
out how to reduce emissions the
companies that feel themselves to be the
most vulnerable to competition from
other places where they won't have will
be subject to similar kinds of
regulations in in general were treated
under the cap-and-trade program in a
special way first of all we started the
program by giving away allowances as
opposed to auctioning them economists
would tell us the most efficient way to
do this is to auction all the allowances
they discover the price that way fair
competition and so forth but we believed
that this program was going to be tough
enough to get going that we should start
it a little more gradually and so early
on Governor Schwarzenegger made it known
that he wanted to see us give away the
bulk of the allowances for the first few
years of the program so we designed the
program that way and in deciding how to
give the allowances away at the
beginning we basically looked at
individual sectors of our economy like
cement plants or oil refineries or
manufacturing facilities looked at
whether that particular sector was
facing a great deal of exposure to trade
and competition which we did using
basically federal government sources and
then allocated within that sector based
on the efficiency of individual firms so
just to take the oil refining sector as
an example they received as a group the
13 refineries in California 90 percent
of emissions allowances that they needed
to cover all of their emissions at the
very beginning just handed the motor
they still had this ten percent gap and
within that 90 percent individual
refiner
were rewarded for being the most
efficient so the refineries that had the
highest output per unit of co2 got all
their allowances whereas those who used
a lot more energy to produce their fuels
got less and that of course was once
they realized what was happening that
set off a lot of discontent among them
and complaints about some people being
trade exposed and so forth but in that
particular industry even though they
have made a strong argument that they
are exposed to trade because we import
fuels from other places other stays we
can bring in on tankers etc they also
have the ability to sell their product
elsewhere - I mean they operate it in a
totally global environment so we did not
treat them as being highly trade exposed
on the other hand there are some
companies that we felt were highly trade
exposed and for those sectors we gave
them a hundred percent of their
allowances to start with with an
agreement that we would monitor the
situation and that's the other thing
that you know thinking about how you can
make something this big and complicated
actually happen is people knew that we
were going to be reevaluated this
program on an annual basis we have
quarterly auctions we reevaluate
people's allocations every year if we
see that we are in fact experiencing
leakage because business is going to
other places we have the ability to
adjust before this becomes a major
problem and I think the sense that I'm
not saying that everyone thinks our
program is wonderful or that they trust
the Air Resources Board to do this
perfectly that would be far from true
but I think there's a sufficient degree
of belief that we will be able to adjust
and that will respond to the political
process so that people were willing to
go forward with this program with that
understanding so moving to the topic of
the auction I call myself from Europe
and we had a similar experience we
started giving all the permits for free
actually by law it had to be at least 95
percent for free by law some people some
countries went up to hundred percent but
now as the program evolves we are
getting more and more revenue from
unions because we have been reducing in
a sense we have been producing over time
the number of free allowances that we
get so I was wondering in California
what are the plans as these revenues
potentially grow in the future what are
the plans for those revenue actions well
the first of all we we are auctioning
from the beginning to different kinds of
allowances with the electric utility
sector those companies PG&E for example
who are regulated by the Public
Utilities Commission and operate under a
regulation for the benefit of consumers
are required to put all their free
allowances up for auction and then to
buy back what they need so that's a
large volume of the allowances that
we're in the auctions the first two
auctions are from the utilities the
state itself kept back about ten percent
of the total allowances and each in each
compliance period with the idea that we
would auction those and then the revenue
could be used to pursue a variety of
different programs that would be helpful
in achieving our a b32 goals
so the the auction of state allowances
is relatively small and one of the
things that I think has been kind of
interesting to watch is how you know
press and critics of the program first
were complaining that we were conducting
any kind of an auction and you know
raking in all this money for the state
now they're complaining not enough money
they want more money this is such a
great program why aren't you getting you
know twenty dollars instead of ten
dollars for an allowance so it's a this
is kind of a mixed bag and one of the
things that I find myself constantly
explaining in various different forums
is this isn't actually not a program
about raising revenue it is not a
program about creating a market the
market is incidental
to our goal which is reducing co2 and
meeting our goals and so you know it's
kind of a strange new world in which an
air pollution regulatory agency is
running this market but we are believers
and we think we've got enough experts
helping us from people who do run
markets and who know what what the
pitfalls and opportunities are that we
can do this you know with integrity and
and and get results but also have it be
a valid market however at the end of the
day we're trying to get rid of the
commodity that we're dealing with here
so this is not something that can it's
not sustainable forever you know as a as
a market program and that's that's a big
difference I think
so you mentioned California as being
some sort of a lap for the United States
so I was wondering how experience is
being received in Washington DC and what
are the perspectives have you been
sharing the experiences and are there
any what are the interactions and the
potentials of California bringing
climate change policy in the US well
there was a huge amount of consternation
leading up to the launch of this program
I think there were many people who were
honestly surprised that we actually went
forward and flipped the switch on
auction day and opened it up and that it
actually worked
that is the computers didn't crash the
electricity did not crash lights didn't
go out and you know the economy didn't
crater obviously that's not really the
test of success so it's gonna take a
while I think before people are willing
to say this program really is what they
would like to pursue I think that the
interest in our ability to do this
program has actually been much greater
in other parts of the world and in some
other states too because as it appears
that it's possible but not very likely
that we're going to see action at the
rational level that will really
meaningfully move us towards a national
climate program more people I think are
coming to the view that it's likely that
the administration will use the
authority that it has under the Clean
Air Act and bring other laws into play
too and and other financial incentive
programs that are administered by do e
for example or the Department of
Transportation but that there will be
something that looks like what we're all
used to in the way of air pollution
policy which is the federal government
putting out a number or a requirement
for emissions and then allowing the
states to develop their own plans for
how they will get there including doing
it in completely different ways as long
as they can demonstrate that their
program is equivalent in terms of
effectiveness to what the federal
government is doing in a world like that
there will be a number of states that
will be interested in what California is
doing there already of course are states
in New England that have experience with
auctioning allowances so it's not like
we're the only people who've ever done
anything with auctions but in terms of
putting together a full-blown climate
program I think California is in fact
the only state in the country other
countries that are pursuing their own
versions of cap-and-trade including
China which is launched five
experimental as they call them pilot
programs for cap and trade any one of
which is as big as most countries would
be Australia which is moving towards a
carbon market some of our friends in
Canada and Canadian provinces and so
forth are very closely following what
we're doing and we're sharing a lot of
detailed practical information about how
we've how we're running the auctions and
how we've decided how to deal with
offsets and things like that but
Washington not so much
so and I understand that passing
regulation and moving forward is full of
challenges before we open the floor for
questions I was wondering in your ideal
world imagined regulation was just like
taking a blank sheet and designing
climate how would you think would be a
good way of going forward for example
the federal level well you know we
watched from here when the waxman-markey
legislation moves through the house and
then failed to be brought up in the
Senate and I'm speaking of course as
somebody who has been a regulator and a
bureaucrat for now the majority of my
career but I do believe that one of the
biggest problems with the waxman-markey
legislation was it attempted to solve
all problems balance all the equities
make all the decisions about who was
going to get what by way of allowances
and revenue under this program in a
piece of congressional legislation so
the thing was you know several feet sick
it was impossible to read and it was so
full of compromises not the compromises
wrong compromises necessary to get
legislation passed and there's nobody
who's better at it than Henry Waxman but
what he ended up with was a bill that
didn't allow any room to breathe it
didn't allow for change it didn't allow
for learning it didn't allow for things
that might go wrong in the
implementation of it as is inevitable so
I do think that there has to be an a
willingness to lay out some general
principles whether you do it through a
tax a cap-and-trade a mixed program like
we have here in California you need to
allow for some agency whether it's EPA
or some new agency to actually put the
program together and make it work
the detailed operation lava that's
that's been my major piece of advice for
people who are thinking about what to do
here I think there are two microphones
on there two hours so if we could first
applause Mary thank you for coming I
understand that the trading is now
essentially done between utilities and I
wonder if that will be deployed so that
the public can get involved either by
way of say owning solar panels on their
roof or some other mechanism
well the cap-and-trade program is only
trading in allowances at this point and
in offsets so there are two different
quantities two different things two
different substances that are being
traded allowances go to people who are
under the cap who are required to be
capped so you and your rooftop are not
going to be given allowances or because
you're not you're not required to cap
your emissions your way of playing in
this program of getting a benefit from
it is several there are several
possibilities one is your utility is
gonna want to get you to put a solar
roof on because they're gonna save money
themselves over what they would have to
pay for allowances if they're
responsible now for serving you
electricity so they get you off their
system from the point of view of having
to buy allowances you sell them back
your excess electricity you become part
of their network this is a movement in
that direction as is there are other
policies also that are moving us in that
direction
the other thing is that non capped
sectors do have the ability to become
sellers of offsets if they can establish
that they are doing something that's
real verifiable in excess of any legal
regulatory
requirement and enforceable overtime
this is a very rigorous and rigid
program on purpose because we were very
concerned as we were designing this
program about offset programs that had
been instituted in other parts of the
world that turned out to be people
trading in illusory credits that things
that really didn't result in any
emissions reductions or double counting
things that they would have done anyhow
and we're not against people making
money but we're against people claiming
credit for doing things if it's not
moving us in the direction of actually
getting more reductions so it's a very
limited world you didn't ask the
question this way but I'm gonna push it
a little bit further I do think that in
the future and hopefully the
not-too-distant future we are going to
see communities cities or counties or
other entities at a regional level
aggregating projects if they can figure
out how they can actually measure and
monitor and enforce the reductions and
and getting credit for them I mean right
now we have one small program which
rewards people for creating or
maintaining urban forests where a city
can demonstrate that they are growing
their trees longer caring for them
better storing more carbon than the norm
and you know you have to establish a
baseline and look at what kinds of trees
they're growing it's you know incredibly
detailed but enough of this has now been
done so that we believe you actually can
have a credible program like that and I
think there will be programs like that
for alternative energy and in
communities as well long answer sorry
I'll try to be quicker thank you so much
for coming Nicholas um so as you
probably know your colleagues at the
department of oil gas and geothermal
resources are bracing for a big boom in
production in the Monterey shale and as
their colleagues in other state
like North Dakota and Colorado and Texas
have found that means a massive increase
in both conventional air pollutants and
methane so I was wondering what if
anything carb is doing to address those
methane emissions under a B 32 well
right now all we're trying to do is to
monitor what's going on so that we're
not ignoring them and you know turning a
highway while the while the emissions
actually grow and as you know there's a
lot of controversy about what the
leakage is right now from existing
operations and how well we're capturing
that as well as what's likely to happen
in the future although there's a lot of
talk about the Monterey shale and the
interest in developing it you know this
is mostly petroleum it's not primarily a
gas resource and right now despite the
talk we're not seeing a huge rush of
people coming in to develop that
particular resource they've got plenty
to do for the moment with the drilling
for gas and for you know with the
current conventional conventional
meaning you know steam injected kind of
programs that are going on right now in
California but it is important that you
know we are a big oil-producing State
there's no question about it we were big
users and we're big producers and we're
looking for ways to get a better handle
on that there's a lot of controversy
about this element of it but one of the
things that we have been quite active in
is looking to evaluate and to if at all
possible promote use of carbon capture
and sequestration in existing oil fields
because geologically they're suited for
this purpose you've got the co2 there
it's being used anyway we'd like to see
it being sequestered and and kept in
underground formations for as long as
possible so that's that's our main role
here hi Mary Clara pondered climate
works Foundation how are you I'm great
thank you so much for being here I hope
this isn't too much of a bittersweet
question but we all watched with bated
breath as your name was banned
about on very short lives lists or EPA
and what advice would you give
administrator McCarthy
what would you be focusing on right now
if that was your job and related to that
do you think the administration's focus
on giving EPA greater authority over
carbon emissions is the better
alternative to pushing a more political
solution in the Congress well thank you
I have to say I was bemused flattered I
was always flattering to have your name
bandied about for a presidential
appointment but I never wanted to go to
Washington to do this I've been there
I've done that not doing that again
particularly in light of the fact that
we have this wonderful opportunity here
in California to not just begin but to
really carry through on our commitments
to learn and to do more and to and to be
a light to the world and we've had
governors in both Governor
Schwarzenegger and Governor Brown who
are willing and able to do that to put
their political prestige and the glamour
of the state of California behind this
issue it's it's fascinated both of them
and they've given it tremendous support
so I could not be in a better position
to do the kind of work that I want to do
Gina McCarthy is a very good friend and
Ally of mine we worked together during
the Bush years conspired would not be
the wrong word to use to try to push the
federal government to support some of
the things that we were trying to do
particularly with clean cars and fuels
she is a terrific person for this
position and I do hope that with her
appointment and the appointment of of
Professor Moniz to be the head of do-e
that the president has a team of people
with the right kind of scientific
administrative and political chops to
put together a strong
program to push what he's already said
he wants which is a climate program that
includes a recognition that we have a
very diverse energy mix in this in the
United States and that we're gonna have
to push very hard for all the
alternatives and the cleaner the cleaner
fuels but at the same time we're gonna
have to continue to live with petroleum
as a fuel for a long time to come how to
put that all together and not exceed our
what what the carrying capacity of the
world is is obviously not an easy
question to answer but there's not a
shortage of people here who are smart
enough to help figure it out the
shortages of the political glue to pull
all of this together and although you
know we chose to go the particular route
that we've gone here in California we're
very eager to collaborate to assist and
to work with any alternative program
that anybody can come up with I'm not at
all eager to continue doing this all by
ourselves I mean we need to have the
United States at the table in the world
and taking action at the federal level
to to deal with the country as a whole
but when we see how this is shaping up
we can then come in and help either by
providing support and assistance to
other states by merging our program into
a federal program I mean for all of the
reasons that both environmentalists and
businesses initially supported
California as a leader on this we also
need to then make sure that we can help
transition into an effective national
program Mary thanks first coming tonight
you've reminded us that you have the
scientific political and administrative
chops to make a really complicated
program to bring it to power and to take
something that we've all been hearing
about academically as a possibility the
actual day to day making
and I wondered what was really
impressive was your thinking about how
you can adjust that you're gonna have to
be adjusting I was wondering if you
could go into a little more detail as to
some of the adjustments some of the
things you're gonna be watching to
figure out how you can manipulate the
program in the future the other thing
I'd like to talk about is someone in the
water side I'm really interested in have
you thought at all about expanding it to
other things and as you monetize carbon
emissions
the other big issue coming up for the
state is nitrogen emissions and there's
some trade-offs back and forth of should
we be maximizing carbon or nitrogen and
how should we be doing I don't know if
you've been thinking across agencies
about that or well a little bit but it's
a really important question so let me
answer the easier one first in terms of
how we're looking at changing things
that need to be changed
I'll give an example of a program that's
a kind of front and center right now in
terms of political controversy in
Sacramento which is our low carbon fuel
standard which we enacted several years
ago but didn't really start putting
pressure on to to see reductions
happening until just recently so the oil
industry is now very exercised about the
fact that we're going to make them
either use lower carbon fuels or buy
credits from a bank that we've set up
the bank has at the moment lots of
credits in it because the way the rule
was set up companies could come in and
by establishing that they have cleaner
alternative fuels on an offer that they
are actually able to sell they can get
credits that then the oil companies can
buy needless to say the companies are
not happy about having to buy credits I
mean that's just not it's not how they
do business that's not what they want to
do their vision of how they were going
to comply with this program was that
there was going to be plenty of enix
pensive biofuels around that they would
be able to use to stretch you know their
their gasoline supplies and that
industry has not come along as quickly
as everybody had hoped and so many of
the credits that are actually in our
bank at the moment are credits that are
coming from the electricity sector
well guess which industry is now very
enthusiastically defending the low
carbon fuel standard and we're not
exactly sorry about that because you
know longer term we want to see a
transition to electric vehicles plug-in
vehicles of a variety of kinds and so
you know the idea that there would be
some money changing hands which would
help get more charging stations out
there into workplaces and apartment
buildings and so forth is not something
that we think is a bad idea
but it's this thing is coming to a head
in the next couple of years and we're
probably gonna have to find some way to
make adjustments in the way the rule
works to recognize that the original
purpose hasn't quite panned out the way
we hoped it would at the same time and
this is just you know kind of the art of
regulation it isn't a science if you
look like you're backing off or no
longer interested in these new advanced
fuels people who've invested significant
amounts of money and who have great
technologies are going to be left
stranded and you not only lose
credibility you lose an opportunity to
really reward people who've done very
important work so we have to find a way
to thread through this needle making
whatever adjustments need to be made to
keep the program going moving forward
but at the same time not cause a cause a
crash and the only thing I can say about
that is we've done it before so we think
we can we think we can do it again but
as far as the kind of bigger picture of
you know the atmosphere and the nitrogen
versus the versus the carbon
we've really just started talking to our
colleagues in universities and in the
water world about how to think about
this problem we are going to be doing a
new scoping plan
so a b32 was set up with five-year plans
every we have to do a new plan every
five years 2013 we're already due for a
new plan so by the end of this year we
expect to have a plan out which will
have a lot more cross-cutting themes to
it than the last one did so instead of
being just a set of regulations and
programs which is kind of a typical err
regulatory approach to these things
it's going to have a lot more talk about
waste as a whole or agriculture as a
whole and a kind of a lifecycle approach
to how we deal with the overall
greenhouse gas implications of those of
those activities so stay tuned it's
gonna be interesting hi chairman nichols
my name is nicole shoots i'm a second
year MBA student and actually my
question dovetails I think pretty neatly
with the end of your last answer so what
what is really struck me is that ARB has
been asked to do things that it's never
done before with the development of the
ab32 program and I wonder if you can
talk about some of the challenges you
faced as an organization growing to meet
those needs and any maybe any areas of
expertise that you're still working on
that's a good question and will there be
jobs in the future I hope so
so one of the things that the
legislature did when they passed a b32
and I just I can't begin to tell you how
important this is is that they gave us
FTE meaning positions we were allowed to
hire people to implement this totally
new statute so in a situation where
government has not grown and has been
shrinking across the board Air Resources
Board was allowed to grow by a hundred
positions starting back in 2006 in order
to put together this probe
and what we did because we had to move
pretty quickly was to fill about half
the positions with people that we were
able to attract from other agencies
within state government and the other
half with people coming in many cases
straight out of universities or the
private sector and so we really for the
first time in a long time had an
infusion of wonderful people with
diverse backgrounds and you know all the
education that you know we that we
really need we didn't we have not been
able to keep every one of those people
but we've kept quite a lot of them I
mean you know state government is not a
place you go for rising salary
expectations if you're motivated by
working on big exciting projects and
important things it is a good place to
work it has the benefits that government
service usually does in terms of you
know if you stick around long enough to
earn a pension you can you know you can
get a pension you think the healthcare
benefits are good but mostly it's
something people do because they just
want to be in them in the middle of the
action and so we have been able to hire
some really terrific
young people and just create a whole new
infusion of energy and frankly a whole
new generation of of people some of whom
at least will stay with state government
and parenthetically that's how we were
able to succeed in air pollution is that
Jerry Brown when he was governor the
first time did the exact same thing for
ARB to enable us to have a program that
actually effectively dealt with smog and
we became the premier air quality agency
that we are because we were allowed to
to bring in really dedicated competent
people now in those days we were hiring
atmospheric chemists petroleum engineers
on a motive engineers and we hired
people away from from auto companies and
you know we people wanted to be here
because this was the place to be if you
thought you could you know build cool
cars that also didn't produce much air
pollution this was the place to be and
now we're hoping it's gonna be the place
to be
for other purposes as well but of course
it's not just a RB that's doing all this
either I mean as we see how complex this
issue is and how many different actions
need to happen in order to really build
an economy and a society that our small
have a smaller carbon footprint we need
people working in the energy agencies we
need people in the housing agencies we
need you know every every piece of our
of our government has to be infused with
this kind of thinking and that's that's
the fun part and I think there are going
to be opportunities as as time goes on
to work in this area so good question
I'll add my thanks thank you very much
the going back to maybe Mike and Jack's
comments that the science is settled the
policy isn't and your challenge with DC
and maybe thinking regionally
California's leadership might might be
pulling Oregon in Washington along
Oregon's a fairly progressive governor
and Washington with jay Inslee may be a
leader in this topic and I just wonder
if there any conversations or any way of
thinking about the leadership and would
that help California implement if Oregon
and Washington absolutely we have had
conversations at the level of the three
governor's about things they would like
to work on together all three of them
are fearless in terms of being able to
mention the word climate change in
public and being willing to take action
to promote clean technology in their
states one of the great things about
governor's is that they are all CEOs and
they all compete with each other for
bragging rights and for being able to
move their own states along so you can't
just say I'm from California I'm here to
help you Oregon figure out how to you
know do a better job with your climate
program but where they find things that
they really can collaborate on
the governor's can work together and
right now they've got a couple things
that they're working on one of which is
expanding the market for plug-in
vehicles where they've been talking
about policies programs and money
actually working together to build the
electric vehicle fleets for state and
local governments not just passenger
cars but all the kinds of working
vehicles that you know governments use
and they're looking at ways to make
their paving more efficient to share and
collaborate on advances in building
technology so there's actually you know
quite a lot going on none of it is quite
you know at the at the press-conference
level at this point but there's a lot of
a lot of discussion going on and I think
there will be there always has been you
know some degree of unity among the
three coastal West Coast states we have
a lot in common with each other in terms
of our the value we place on our
environment and our coastlines and so I
think there's gonna be a little bit more
collaboration in that regard and that
will be helpful in dealing with
Washington also good question I'm here
as a critic in September it'll be sixty
years that I started working on energy
forty-five of which were taken up with
research and development I was an
important part of inventing a new
technology that's widely used in
California inventing developing and
commercializing it there palm fronds
being made into electricity in Mecca
California rice halls near san griento
wood wastes up and down the state I
remember some of the Fiasco's in
regulation in California I remember the
first attempt for electric vehicle
the I remember the argument I had with
one of the board members why don't you
try hybrids first oh we can't do that oh
but my argument you could you could
actually have batteries developed and
experiments why are you nodding at me I
will get to the questioned the other
Fiasco was the attempt at not building
electricity plants that cost gray
Davis's seat as governor why do you
think that this effort will not end in
electricity shortages outages Fiasco's
like those two I think thanks for coming
it's a pleasure to be here and I wasn't
expecting to come to a university and
not hear a little bit of dissension or
criticism so thank you for that too
so I think that the issue about
electricity shortages that's just the
piece of this and I've got to focus on
is extremely important I I don't share
your view that the reason why we had the
electricity crisis of 2000 2001 was that
we hadn't built enough power plants but
I agree with you that it was what cost
gray Davis's job and I can assure you
that no governor ever wants to have that
happen again and it's been very much
part of our thinking in designing this
program that we would be working with
not only electric utilities but others
who have a stake in power supply and
power use to make sure that that didn't
happen so as you know it's a it's a
large complex market for electricity
California does not generate all its own
electricity we import a great deal of
our electricity and one of the things
that the legislature did which I think
was unique as far as I know
was to take responsibility for the
carbon emitted from the electricity that
we import so we didn't just say we're
only gonna deal with what we're doing
inside our borders we said if we're
bringing these electrons in we're also
going to be responsible for the carbon
that we're causing even if it's in
somebody else's backyard and that has
made designing this program very
complicated and it is one of the things
that we're keeping an eye on very
closely we are working with the
California Independent System Operator
which is the entity that's responsible
for keeping the lights on there are
balancing Authority that's responsible
for all of the reliability regulations
at the federal level and they are
extremely alert to anything that looks
like it's going to cause a shortage in
supply or a collapse in the in the
transmission system or a shortage of
voltage and all that sort of thing and
we meet on a very regular basis with
them as well as with the Public
Utilities Commission and the Energy
Commission to make sure that our our
policies are working together we are
facing a very serious problem right now
in Southern California which is where
I'm from but it will affect the whole
state because of the outage at San
Onofre the fact that we're missing one
of our major base load power plants
because of the safety concerns there we
were able to get through last summer as
a result of some fairly innovative
things that the that the agencies did
including allowing a couple of plants
that had been shut down to start up
again during the summer but that's not a
permanent or long-term solution and
we're very busy right now looking at a
series of things that we can do to bring
more electricity online without
compromising our other goals as well and
obviously that does include a lot more
focused effort on demand management and
making the system more
flexible so I wanted to actually very
briefly address one of the earlier
questions that was asked about how
Californians can get more individually
involved in a b32 in the cap and trade
so I started a not-for-profit which is
called carbon lighthouse Association if
you donate we will aggregate up your
donations and actually buy allowances at
quarterly auction so I'd get a kick out
of that I do have a question did you
register them as a in the auction right
yeah we so the individuals are
registered the entity is not it just
received its its papers today actually
so little next next time so I think
California has had some incredibly
successful policies that have actually
had great energy impacts outside of the
state so specifically a lot of the stuff
with compliant with appliance standards
has impacted national and actually
global energy use and actually the Evi
program which was eventually pulled also
would have had a lot of implications
nationally for car manufacturers and I'm
curious what other parts of a b32 and
other things carb is doing in general
are sort of aimed towards having a more
national impact with regards to energy
reduction that I can get excited about
well in terms of looking at efficiencies
or pulling in new technologies I
mentioned the low carbon fuel standard
which was explicitly aimed at trying to
promote investment and commercialization
of advanced biofuels and other
alternatives to petroleum as well our
car standards by themselves you know
just having to push down on the on the
emissions of co2 have led to real
innovations in the way cars are made and
and what they emit we have a program
which hasn't gotten as much attention
publicly that requires all major
emitters to perform an audit of their
energy use and to look for
ways in which they could save more
energy above and beyond what they're
doing right now as a result of the
utility programs and that's turning up
some very interesting stuff which we're
going to be putting out publicly soon
but we're not we're just collating and
all right now I think that the energy
Commission's work on new building
standards and what the PUC has done with
a Net Zero policy for new construction
in California is incredibly exciting and
as the economy starts to pick up again
we're seeing a tremendous activity on
the part of builders of both homes and
commercial buildings and competing with
each other once again for the most
energy-efficient and attractive
buildings that they can come up with so
I think there's still a lot of
opportunity out there the part that
probably excites me the most and I don't
know if it does you but you know I'm a
city person I live in Los Angeles and so
what I'm excited about is what's going
on at the local level with communities
really taking a look at how you can
retrofit older cities and make them more
efficient not just in terms of their
buildings but in the need that people
may have to get in their cars and drive
just the fact that we're really looking
now at making our communities walkable
and bikable and that people are looking
to live in places like that that we're
looking at people not just being forced
to but actually seeking to live in
places where they can use transit you
know this is a this is a new era for
California and I think we're gonna do it
in a some kind of a uniquely California
way I mean it's not going to be
Manhattan but it's gonna be pretty cool
I my question is about 350.org and I'm
wondering if it has had much impact on
California legislation and do you have
an opinion about it that you could share
with us whether it is a plus or a minus
well I don't think it's a - but it
hasn't been terribly influential in
California either and I'm not sure
exactly why I mean it has you know
clearly people follow what what's been
talked about but I don't see it as
having really had impact at the level of
the legislature unfortunately you know
the legislature mostly pays attention to
the people that are there all the time
demanding things of the helm and that
tends to be existing industries and and
the lobbying groups that they hear from
all the time so it takes a while for
something new and with a different
perspective to really get heard inside
inside Sacramento I think that you know
we we wouldn't have had a b32 if it
hadn't been for the unique coalition
that occurred there between
environmental organizations and some
leading-edge businesses in California
and I don't think 350 or really has had
that same level of cohesion yet that
would have really enabled it to to have
a big impact at the legislative level
but I think there's you know a lot of
people are reading and getting ideas
from a lot of different places these
days and so you never know quite how
it's gonna filter in thank you you
mentioned some of the emerging carbon
markets in China and Australia but you
didn't mention the European ETS which is
the big one and I'm wondering because
there was a recent book published by a
an Oxford professor called the carbon
crunch which makes the case that the ETS
which also gave away very generous
allowances to industry has in fact not
really had any impact on reducing carbon
emissions in Europe that it was really
the process of Adi industrialization and
I'm just wondering what California how
did you look at Europe and what did you
learn from it
good question what I think we learned is
not to be so generous in giving away
allowances we did give away allowances
but we only gave away what people were
actually using your didn't have such
good information when they began their
program they relied on the individual
countries to just kind of come up with
their numbers themselves uh when we
started our program we did it based on a
pretty well vetted inventory we had been
collecting mandatory data from the major
industries in California for several
years and having it audited by
independent external auditors before we
even started designing the cap-and-trade
program when we did start printing up
allowances and talking to people about
them of course we had companies that
came in and said oh no no we really were
emitting a lot more than that but you
know we had the evidence of what they
had submitted and so we were in pretty
good shape when it came to not
overstating what the emissions were and
then as I mentioned earlier on a
sectoral basis we didn't give away a
hundred percent of the allowances even
at the starting point we gave away 90%
of the allowances and then except for
the electric utilities a different
different situation but for most of the
companies that are under this rule
utilities got a hundred percent because
they're required to auction and then use
the proceeds for the benefit of their
customers so they're in a different in a
whole different situation so I think
that we learned a lot from the EU we
actually had when I first got to
Sacramento we had one of the carbon
experts from from the UK who came in and
spent six months basically embedded at
the ARB while we were working on the
program and although there are obviously
security issues around all of this I
mean we do have trade secrets for
companies that we maintain and there's
not all the information about the
auctions is public we're looking at the
potential for actually trading staff
with China
and allowing to have some experts from
the NDRC in China working side-by-side
with our folks to talk through a lot of
the design elements which sounds simple
when you talk about them on the kind of
charts that we saw earlier but are
incredibly complicated to actually work
through